[Musique]
pendant la guerre cachée après on sera
aux témoignages de barbara en répétition
à châteauroux a été recueilli par gérard
vergès pour son film barbara ma plus
belle histoire d'amour
sylvie et bordeaux la chanteuse y évoque
sa petite enfance et sa vie d'avant
l'immense vedette qu'elle est devenue
dans les années 70 et révèle qu'elle a
vécu à deux reprises dans la foulée
quand ils trinquent a été attaqué dans
la plaine de châtillon où son père ça ne
l'est pas mais moi j'étais dans le train
moi c'est vrai je connais très bien
votre région
[Musique]
la petite fille était dans le wagon t'as
pas été mieux
le coteau n'oserait fin juin 1940 comme
des millions de français barbara qui n'a
que 10 ans qui se retrouvent sur les
routes de l'exode des bonu par sa mère
en poste à la préfecture de blois a eu
vent de la coupure des feux sur la loire
avec sa tante et son frère et g dans un
train arrêté en rase campagne à
châtillon-sur-indre les occupants
camperont une quinzaine de jours
attendant une hypothétique locomotive et
les wagons seront bombardés par les
allemands elle fera partie des rescapés
est accueilli dans le village de près ou
dans l'indre d'abord hébergé dans
l'école communale elle trouve refuge
avec sa tante et son frère dans un des
établissements du village le café
lanchais qui dispose de quatre chambres
à l'étagé le bâtiment existe toujours
situé face à l'église son propriétaire
nous a ouvert ses portes les la forme ou
de barbares se situe ici avec une
ouverture de toit sur la rue et une
ouverture sur l'arrière et comme vous le
voyez fait en mauvais état c'est à
restaurer en totalité dans la caucase
hymne au fond du jardin de la tuilerie
attenante au café lanchais une petite
maison aujourd'hui désaffectée en 1940
elle abritait la famille d'origine à 77
ans plus tard cette dernière a tenu à
témoigner sur les lieux mêmes où petite
fille de 11 ans elle jouait
quotidiennement avec celles qui ne
s'appelait pas encore barbara mais
monique serre et qui du haut de ses 10
ans affirme et déjà qui voulait
l'entendre son intention d'être une
artiste dont on s'amusait à jouer tout
ça et on est
j'avais un petit piano l'arrêt n'est les
jouets de ses
de rémy la perdrix mi fa sol le symbole
famille rey dans un pré miled au thon
dans l'eau voilà une petite cantate du
coup des lois obsédante uma dorante
menthe verte ou une petite cantate comme
nous jouions autrefois ça le jeu l'ajout
maladroite similaires et 100 dos c'est
tout mais ne leur est celle enchaîne
alors amenés dans la cour
celle là ça faisait la cour à l'or
vienne à une autre jacqueline leclercq
qui menait océans se retrouver comme ça
on joue et nous avons également retrouvé
jacqueline installé depuis les années 70
à châtillon-sur-indre à une dizaine de
kilomètres de préau
tous ces souvenirs sont dans sa tête car
nul photos de barbara même de classe
témoigne de cette époque là il venait
pratiquement tous les jours à la maison
enfin l'été plus proche de ce côté là
pour jouer avec regina parce qu'il était
le même pour l'heure naturellement moi
il y avait un petit peu de différence
pour enfournement fait un peu par contre
quand tu as avec mon père allait à la
ferme est le cheval elle était l'âme
alors à l'humidité
bébel parce qu on la plus belle alors la
plèbe et belle tu prochaine alors il
s'appelle mustapha ce le cheval alors
apporté avec lui alors la halle était
heureuse comme tout jeu partir là mais
s'il où on va elle chantait beaucoup
alors à l'école mais c'était madame
longue et qui nous faisait les cours
elle était dans la classe inférieure
mais n'empêche qu'on est étroit qu'on
avait des mois c'est vrai que j'aurais
pu la suivre
bon bref elle disait déjà cette époque
la part du lustre chanteuse willow
fallait pas que le guide de mons à temps
parce qu'alors là
vous n'êtes pas d'une scène dans sa
famille mais mon dos nu à l'école
l'arbre m'a donné des coups comme autant
de mon enfance et longtemps j'ai fermé
les yeux je crois que j'ai prié je
retrouvais mon innocence avant que le
soir de ce report j'ai voulu voir mais
elles ont pleuré sous les roses j'ai
voulu voir le jardin à la mairie de
préaux malgré des recherches dans les
registres le nom de monique sert
n'apparaît pas même dans celui de
l'école
une précaution peut-être pour protéger
la petite fille juive et sa famille par
mois on n'a pas de trace vraiment écrit
tuer tout le monde le sait tout le monde
tous les anciens qui sont encore de ce
monde
lormont connu sur la l'école avec elle
plusieurs personnes qui sont fils l'ont
fréquentée qui elle est qui ont joué
avec elle mais et laissez passer
incognito sur les sur les dossiers est
toujours temps arrive après on m'a
finalement rien n'indique jusqu'ici fait
conseil municipal et moi envisageons de
faire poser une plaque commémorative
comme quoi elle a vécu un peu plus d'un
an et sur le vote sur le bâtiment
adéquate sur parce qu'on a la chance
qu'il existe toujours chancellerie la
personne le propriétaire jouent le jeu
puis a envie de faire revivre la
situation il aura fallu que
l'association locale art et savoir faire
héberger dans l'ancien café lanchais
pour son exposition annuelle décide de
rendre hommage à barbara pour que
l'histoire de la chanteuse recommencent
à se répandre
hors de la commune en cette année de
commémoration des 20 ans de sa
disparition
james allard n'est pas étranger à cette
renaissance le propriétaire a entrepris
la rénovation du lieu
aimerait y associer la mémoire de la
chanteuse le projet final n'est pas figé
cependant j'en entends bien restauré la
totalité si possible de cette bâtisse
envisager la restauration
et j'ai serré de renouveler la chambre
de barbara non pas avec le mobilier
qu'elle a connue parce qu'il a disparu
depuis longtemps mais avec du mobilier
d'époque et peut-être que je ne pense
pas l'année prochaine mais les années
suivantes
lorsqu'on fera l'exposition peinture on
aura j'espère la possibilité d'accéder à
l'étagé et que les visiteurs puissent
aller jusqu'à dans la chambre qu'à
occuper barbara bien c'est la chambre de
barbara enfants a disparu
celle où jeune femme de 27 ans elle
réside à plus de six mois
existe toujours à quelques encablures de
là à la sortie de buzançais chez iw et
sylvie du manoir dont elle évoquait les
noms dans la séquence du film
si l'homme oiseau l'évidence s est loin
du château du bois renaud
sylvie iep bordeaux dans cette opération
en juin 1957
dix sept ans après son premier séjour
dans l'indre barbara débarque avec son
amoureux de l'époque jean poissonnier
dit toto au château de boiro nos amis de
longue date du propriétaire il est venu
pour trouver refuge et travail
barbara pour mettre au point son tour de
chant la suite sylvie nous la raconte il
n'avait pas un sou ils sont venus tous
les deux ici et elles pour faire son
piano elle faisait un piano tous les
jours tous mes joueurs
c'est là qu'elle a appris son métier
enfin tous et b comment comme comme
jeune femme s'était du jeune femme
guéant joué très très très dangereux
elle faisait plein de bêtises
l'adolescent c'est difficile à dire ça
quand même par exemple dans un temps et
se précipiter les et j'ai faim qui à
l'aller rire là
la soupe déchirant enfin la mangez pas
beaucoup mais elle prenait appui la
soupe du chien tellement jolie quand
c'est vrai là
savons pas du tout sa vie antérieure et
comme elle était très discrète elle n'en
parlez pas avec du sérieux bras tous les
jours elle venait dans cette pièce qui
n'étaient pas appliquées il est juste le
piano et puis des meubles très chic et
dans le froid le plus total dans chaud
et dans le froid après parce qu'elle
restait jusque jusqu'au mois de janvier
derrek lee parti monstres divers me
marier et moi alors ils sont partis et à
la bi a fait parce que c'est là que ça a
été tout de suite à lécluse
une neutralité que c'est grâce à vous qu
elle a eu sa première vraie robe de
scène est ce que c'est exactement mari
qu'il a un qui leur donnait ça quand ils
sont partis puis acheté sa robe de scène
[Musique]
un vêtement
yves et sylvie reverrons barbara en
allant à ses concerts elle reviendra une
fois avoir ono avec l'amour de sa vie
yves derbez l'est qui lui inspira ce
célèbre chanson dis quand reviendras tu
sylvie décidera de faire chambre d'eau
dans les années 85 sur le site internet
l'histoire de barbara figure aux côtés
de celle d'yves du manoir rugbyman de
légende et oncle de son mari aujourd'hui
ce sont ces petits enfants qui accueille
la clientèle qui a le privilège de
dormir là où barbara vécu six mois
j'aime bien certains vieux chanteur
j'aime bien les vieilles chansons je
connais pas très bien barbare année mais
temps en temps j'aime bien ça me plaît
mais sinon ça évoque rien de rien de
personnel j'ai entendu ces histoires de
ma grand-mère est donc tout ça j'en ai
entendu parler mais évidemment je n'ai
pas rencontré
donc pour moi c'est assez waltary vague
mais je trouve ça rigolo parce que oui
ça me plaît me plaît comme chanteuse
donc c'est rigolo de se dire qu'elle
était peut-être un petit précis même si
de la fenêtre de la chambre
on aperçoit le parc et le silo de la
ferme où travaillait totaux que rien n'a
changé ou presque des paysages que
barbara a pu voir lors de son séjour le
temps file inexorablement peut-être un
peu moins vite dans l'indre où dans ces
deux lieux
on peut toujours retrouver sa trace
mais on reviendra tout au moins le sais
tu que cool qu'en coupant ce ne sera
guère que tout le temps perdu
non
des robes ne se rattrapent les seuls
[Musique]